there's teams a few bici on any given
night if you don't come ready to play
cuz of that town
they left hurry in the corner with the
three-point play Robinson said the two
buckets mr. Carey likes to hit threes
hope he's a good defender pretty rugged
Angelo got some space and set another
jumper it goes hit a couple jumpers ties
is over lamina gap final minute here a
but really interesting first half and
will Russell drop it in the three
[Music]
there's not gonna waste my fear than
layman Steph the legs crossover that's
three little bit range jumper just Thank
You Angelo this is absorbing people to
run through
in this scene a lot of pick-and-rolls
here we go again
Steph is three just perfect into the
spacing and the cutting just overall
grass with the offense one thing
off the curry feed marques Chris set
that screen more guide makes it that
much tougher that's discouraging for the
penalty Huffington's a good defense
sighs - mom anyway is nothing more
discouraging I look at Stef look at why
they like him a lot of people saying
he's
blame is Mouse scurry yeah